[Musik]
ein Lied für die Freiheit eine Hymne der
Proteste im Iran der Sänger kurz nach
Erscheinen festgenommen auch in Berlin
gehen Sie auf die Straße fast täglich
demonstrierende im Iran riskieren dafür
ihr Leben
[Musik]
ich für die Leute miran zu merken sie
haben internationale Solidarität das
kommt an trotz Internetzensur kommt es
an ob die Welt sich solidarischzeit mit
ihnen oder nicht vor allem für die
jungen Menschen ist der Iran einfach im
Gefängnis nichts anderes und die
Alternative ist für sie halt keine
Alternative mehr also entweder sie
kämpfen sich jetzt frei sagen sie oder
nicht alle natürlich aber sozusagen sie
sterben und obwohl das iranische Regime
das Internet drosselt und zensiert
füllen unter dem Hashtag ibanprotests
Fotos und Videos die sozialen Netzwerke
Tod dem Diktator schreien diese
Schülerinnen
andere singen
für ihre Zukunft
trotz der Brutalität des Regimes reißt
der Mut nicht ab wie auch diese Frauen
in Tehran zeigen
Ginger Azadi Frau Leben Freiheit schallt
es über die Straßen im Iran
und auch in Berlin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seit dem Tod der 22-jährigen Martha Gina
armini festgenommen wegen eines zu
lockersitzenden Kopftuchs reißt der
Protest nicht ab das Leben von Daniela
seperien Berlin spielt sich seitdem
zwischen Demonstrationen und Internet ab
sie ist 24 ihre Eltern flohen aus dem
Iran noch bevor sie geboren wurde und
doch ist das Land ein so wichtiger Teil
von ihr
meine größte Angst ist dass die Proteste
sich irgendwann auflösen dass die
Menschen keine Kraft mehr haben das sie
kein Support mehr bekommen aus dem
Ausland und das ist am Ende nichts
gebracht hat außer tausende Tote und
verhaftete meine größte Hoffnung ist
natürlich dann andersrum das ist dann
tatsächlich was bringt das ist jetzt das
China die letzte Person war der letzte
staatliche femizid im Iran und ähm ja
dass das Regime gestürzt ist dass wird
dass die Menschen selbst wählen können
wie es mit ihrem Land weitergehen soll
auch Gilde sahibi ist eine der Stimmen
die laut aussprechen was das
regimentäran versucht tot zu schweigen
und niederzuknüppeln
die deutsch-iranische Journalistin hat
Freunde Bekannte Kollegen im Iran die
ihr Informationen schicken
einer sein Leben dafür geben muss dann
ist es halt so
133 Menschen sollen bislang bei dem
Protesten getötet worden sein Menschen
die seit nun 43 Jahren in Unfreiheit
unter einer religiösen Diktatur leben
nur noch diese Islamische Republik kennt
müssen vor allem auch die Leute die
gerade auf der Straße sind und dieser
Tod von Gina armini dieser femizid
dieser Mord Angela armini der hat genau
diese
Grundfesten der der Islamischen Republik
wiedergespiegelt weil es darum geht
Menschen Frauen zu unterdrücken und
Frauen und Männer und alle Geschlechter
können diesen Druck und diesen Hass und
diese diese Unfreiheit einfach
anscheinend nicht mehr aushalten es ist
sagt Gilde sahibi ein feministischer
Protest den es im Iran und in der
gesamten Region noch nicht gegeben hat
millionenfach geteilte kraftvolle Bilder
[Musik]
diese Schwestern die ohne Kopftuch im
Café sitzen sind inzwischen im Gefängnis
aber die Fotos ihres Mutters sind in der
Welt um jeden Tag Bilder wie Frauen ohne
Kopftuch über die Straßen laufen wie sie
tanzen wie sie singen sie singen Cafés
sitzen diese Flamme wird es werden Sie
nie wieder austreten können das glaube
ich nicht und ich glaube das jetzt der
echte Widerstand auch wirklich anfängt
auch der Bundestag beschäftigt sich mit
dem Thema Iran in einer aktuellen Stunde
vergangene Woche Daniela superi ist
persönlich dabei erhofft sich konkretes
Handeln klare Unterstützung von der
deutschen Außenpolitik
wenn die Polizei wie es scheint eine
Frau zu Tode prügelt weil sie aus Sicht
der sittenwärter ihr Kopftuch nicht
richtig trägt dann hat das nichts aber
auch gar nichts mit Religion oder Kultur
zu tun
der schlicht
gesetzliches Verbrechen
und doch ist Daniela Sibirien täuscht
mehr als warme Worte seien das nicht
gewesen die Lage im Iran eskaliert
täglich weiter Studierende der
sharif-universität in Teheran werden von
Sicherheitskräften angegriffen gejagt
mit Säcken über den Köpfen mitgenommen
Daniela seperia organisiert eine
Spontan-Demo vor der iranischen
Botschaft in Berlin in nur einer Stunde
sind über 100 Menschen ihrem Aufruf
gefolgt
und die Familien haben demonstriert von
den Universitäten jedoch haben sie ihre
Kinder nicht gesehen die werden
umgebracht die werden verprügelt wir
wissen nicht was mit ihm passiert und
das ist das wenigste was wir machen
können uns hier versammeln und sie
unterstützen ein Onkel sind auf Demos
Freunde sind oft Demos und manchmal
haben die Internet und schreiben ja uns
geht's gut aber die hören nicht auf die
gehen bis sie bis die dieses Regime
endlich mal weg haben wir können Druck
auf die Politik ausüben um etwas zu tun
also bei Annalena bärburg heute schreibt
die außenpolitischen Grenzen begrenzt
wenn sie mich hier um jetzt zu sagen nee
sind nicht begrenzt es gibt so viel was
Du tun können also zum Beispiel die
iranischen regiemitglieder ausweisen
ihre Visa nicht zu verlängern
gleichzeitig aber als Suchverfahren für
iranische geflüchtete die die wirklich
geflohen sind und nicht
geflogen sind weil sie verfolgt werden
ihren Schutz zu geben
[Musik]
bella ciao auf Persisch
Daniela seperi will weitermachen
Solidarität und Taten einfordern denn
was da gerade im Iran passiert sagt
nicht nur sie ist etwas Großes
[Musik]